very cool very cool where are you
different place anyway
lobby of the new my office yeah
um we i'm working at a new um radio
station group
yeah yeah
and how's the new laptop what did you
get
it's good it's awesome i got a macbook
air
ah okay that's what i'm on too
yeah it's awesome it's so much lighter
than my other computer was so heavy and
my monitor you should have seen it evan
it was like literally falling off like
it was like hanging with the threads of
the monitor
it was so bad i'd had it for like eight
years
so anyway have you used the mac before
are you getting used to the new uh the
operating system change yeah i have used
a mac my last one was a mac it was a
power book so um it's just a little
newer and it's faster and it's you know
got some new stuff
cool okay um so let's start so for those
of you watching
uh i believe every entrepreneur has to
find their one word that defines who
they are and then apply it to their life
and their business and we've been
following jen along her path she's a
copywriter and her one word is fantasy
so how are we doing how's the past month
been what's going on what can we talk
about it's been going good i feel really
good about i finally kind of got my
facebook page going and last time we
talked i barely just set it up so i
think um i think i only had like two two
fans on there
so um since then i've i've
been really consistent with posting some
things and i took your suggestion of
posting um
you know some of the gen thoughts and
some quotes from other people kind of in
my branding
um
similar to what i have on my website and
i also posted um
a couple of fantasies in the in the in
the same writing again it branded with
um branded with
with my website on there so um i like
those and i was really worried about
like not having enough content like not
finding enough content to put on there
and i've been it's been great i feel
like i've been able to put something up
there almost every day so i love it i
feel confident so i've been only invited
a few friends i think i have like 30
people now on there
or so and um not all of them are friends
so some of them um
have must have seen the site through
other friends who liked it or whatever
including you probably so
cool i i liked it i liked it
i'm a fan i follow along
um
i've seen you guys
on twitter you've gotten some you you're
posting some interesting stuff you're
retweeting
that's where you've gotten your biggest
growth so far is from twitter
yes definitely i've done some good
things on twitter i agree and i've been
consistent on there too uh in fact it's
funny because i was kind of laughing
because i've been kind of mad at myself
for not doing as many blog posts as i
want to do um
you know my guy had a goal of doing one
a week even though you and i talked
about doing one every other week i still
wanted to do one a week and um but it's
funny because i still was able to pull
um
some good tweetables out of my post like
almost three works of you know three
weeks of of stuff out of one post so
that was kind of cool at least i was
able to you know
to grab some stuff so
cool now are you are you scheduling out
your tweets or you doing them all live
i'm just doing them all live yeah i
haven't started scheduling them out yet
it's been
fairly easy for me to do with my writing
schedule so that's been good
okay cool
um well let's talk about your progress
here so the blog once a week is not
happening right
nope i think i did one post since we
yeah
so once a month okay
yeah once a month not not really quite
where i want to be
and i haven't done any videos yet and i
almost did a video i was gonna ask we
gotta get them
i know i know
when can we you've done what you've done
two
i've done two i know actually i filmed
more than that i just haven't put them
up um
and i had the idea of doing one this
week and almost i almost did it but i
thought i'd ask your opinion of doing
something that was instead of sort of
like uh
teaching people how to write specific
things about their copy just in general
talking a little bit about fantasy and
and why i use it in my copy and kind of
almost more
philosophical um
and it would be easy for me to do that i
could do it quickly and not have to
overthink like you know specifically how
much you know about all the specific
copy and stuff that because it takes a
little more time to edit that in um
but i wanted to be interesting and
compelling for my for my you know for
someone who might want to watch it so i
just thought i'd ask your opinion about
that
yeah not all the videos have to be the
exactly the same
they don't have to follow all the same
format right and
using
i like what we came up with before where
you had your here here are like the
eight i forget how many steps you have
in your process seven or eight or
whatever it is
uh and then yeah
digging on one of them in the video so
this still applies right if you're
talking about how you use fantasy why
use fantasy that's still part of your
process
yeah right so even if you don't
even if you don't share uh like an
example of
a client work
how better to get something up as also
still a teachable lesson like what am i
going to learn
from this you could tell a story it
doesn't have to be like here's here's
what i've done and show but if you're
telling a story about fantasy and why it
means something to you and how you use
it in your copy
not just not just a summary but like
take me on take me on a story take me on
a fantasy
adventure yeah
exactly
and from there i can learn something
right
um okay it also humanizes you too and
people like
to
know who the person is
behind
this is expert but if you're telling a
personal story about how you went to
i don't know like what what is what is
the story about that you're gonna share
oh gosh i think i was just gonna talk in
general about why i use fantasy and why
i love it and um and i was gonna share a
little bit about how i
how when i fantasized and how it's come
you know how it's come true and um and
how
and how it can be powerful when you're
telling us again telling a story like
you're right on like you're telling a
story to your customers and you're
tapping into what their desires are
um
that how powerful that can be in copy so
that's kind of what i was going to be
talking about
so what's an example of one that's come
true for you
oh gosh there's been too many like if i
write down like i could write down like
a mini conversation i've had with
somebody and
you know like maybe somebody that i just
met that i think is really interesting
and i want to talk to them and
um and then later like a couple months
later i look back at some of my writings
and i literally had that almost exact
conversation things like that
so
what would be really great to see in the
video is you talk you talk on a high
level right so you you introduce this
concept you talk about fantasy talk why
it's important to you
and why it's important for other people
then then you take me on this like give
me a specific so even as you're talking
about this you're
you're summarizing
right i know
like yeah it's a conversation i've had
lots of conversation that i meet with
the person and then
and then it comes true and that was what
i wrote down it was my fantasy king
right so like
give me that one story so i get this
happens to you over and over and over
and over again and that makes sense
because it's your one word
right
make this tangible for me as a viewer by
making me feel that one story so
tell me about you know one guy who you
really wanted to meet and you wrote down
the conversation and what were some of
the things that you wrote down and why
were you excited to meet with this
person and then tell me about the
meeting that you actually had and maybe
you were nervous going in like so
humanizes you
and right
and like i'm sitting imagine like i'm
i'm on the fly on the wall or i'm
sitting on this couch watching you go
through this experience because that's
what's going to make me feel something
instead of just summarizing at a high
level
back to the teachable lesson so you
start with it you start with why it's
important
uh and then you take me on this journey
you always end with this teachable
lesson that i can learn
from the experience that you have
okay and that could just be you
all on camera right it doesn't have to
be you don't have to cut to
um you don't have to cut to uh
somebody's website or copy that you
wrote for them um you know if you wrote
something down maybe you have your
notebook that you can flash up and show
me
some of the things that you wrote you
know
but you don't have to make it too
complicated the power is in the
storytelling but a specific this is the
problem that i had when i first started
doing videos everything was summarized
and it was hard to
connect to and i watched yeah of course
that's what happened what's the problem
i didn't get that
you know you got to get into the
specifics of that one specific story and
by going in detail on one story it helps
me understand the whole concept that
you're trying to get across
right
okay that totally makes sense and that's
exactly
you know
how you make copy really compelling too
right i mean you you tell details and
take someone on a journey yeah yeah
it's it's like anything that's going to
be a muscle that you need to get
better at and you'll you'll get better
as you work it and and your your your
first videos are amazing for a
first-time
person on video that's awesome
uh you're
you're ahead of where i was i'm ahead of
where most people are so that's you're
starting off from a really good place
but uh
you gotta you gotta actually get out
there and do some videos
i agree i totally agree with you and i
know you're totally right because the
more i practice the easier it will come
and i'll become even better and i think
that's just that i i overthink it and
then procrastinate because i'm like oh
it's gotta be perfect you know um rather
than just doing it and getting the
practice from it and making it better
yeah
you may even find that you have some
things that you share on your video that
you could turn into tweets as well if
you're looking for content
um yeah i bet i would
just like you're making blog posts um
that turn into tweets you can get stuff
from your videos as well
when do you have to go back inside
what do you mean go back inside inside
your building when you have to go back
do you have a sign you have to be back
by x time
oh yeah i just have to be back by 11 40.
yeah just because i'm meeting a client
yeah
okay 11 40. so 11 40 what time is it now
we're going to be done at 11 30 your
time right
right exactly
so you've got 10 minutes after our call
to take out your brand new macbook air
and record
okay cool i like this
it's a challenge i love it
it's a one to two minute video
sharing something
even if you don't i would like you to
put it up on your channel but even if
you look at me like okay i'm not gonna
put it up just to have that
practice
okay
okay
you got to get into the habit because
this is this is what is going to
resonate the most with people people can
see you on video and you're sharing your
story that's going to leave an impact
okay
okay so something's going to come up at
least send it to me
okay
by the end of the day send me something
if it doesn't if you don't hit youtube
that's okay but something to me
um okay i love what you've been doing on
twitter especially and it's no surprise
that this is where you're getting your
biggest growth because it's where you're
spending the most time and the most most
thought on it
um you're retweeting what other people
are saying that relate to your theme
which is great
i've seen some of those i've commented
on some of them i love them they're
great uh i like some of the some of your
tweets
great like they were uh
brash opinionated um like this is this
is something that you know you need to
change in your life they're a couple
like wow yeah jen's getting it this is
great awesome
and really i would keep encouraging to
think about that like what is wrong with
the world
and what is the change that you want to
see and share those those thoughts like
let me hear from you as to what
what you think is wrong and how how the
world should be those strong opinions
that you have for a better world is what
is going to get people
interacting with your staff
right some of them were awesome i think
i commented on a few of them but that i
really enjoyed those ones
yeah thank you thank you i um
yeah i feel like something clicked when
i actually watched your video on um how
to write a really powerful tweet and um
and that that kind of was like the
beginning of like sort of like oh
kind of like
it made sense to think i think i was
sort of approaching very tentatively
before sort of like you know according
to other people and sort of but not
you're right i didn't really put up my
opinion like my really strong opinion up
there before and i was like why am i
like why am i hesitating on that so i
just went for it and yeah i ever since
then you've noticed so that's funny
my favorite tweets my favorite tweets
you've been putting up so so keep doing
that like keep posting other people's
tweets that's great retweets awesome
and and i'll encourage you to keep doing
your gen thoughts
from the gut you know this is what i
really feel
uh i know i don't think it would offend
anybody um you know even if you did
whatever it's what you feel but
but um
yeah i love it keep doing that stuff my
favorite stuff like i felt proud like
jen is coming along this is this is
great this is great stuff
good good good guys
um
one thing we talked about last
month was also recognizing people who
are in the same
who believe in the same thing as you
calling them out and saying hey thank
you or calling my champion of the day or
champion of the week that kind of thing
just recognizing people who are on the
same path as you i haven't seen any of
that stuff come out maybe i missed it
but i haven't seen anything come out
yeah i actually just did that i started
it last week so i've done two so far um
and i actually the only reason why i
hesitated i was trying to think of a
a good name for it because i just felt
like
you know champion of the day and that's
very perfect for entrepreneurs but for
me it didn't i don't think it just
didn't work for me and so i was playing
with different names then i finally just
came i just finally decided on fanta
tweeter so fancy tweeter of the week was
what i came up with so and i recognized
people for
um
for inspiring imagination and fantasy is
how i how i um coined it so
okay i haven't seen those you know did
you start the the tweet with the
person's symbol the person's name like
okay so when you do that nobody else
sees it except that person
oh no no i didn't i'm sorry i didn't
start it with their name i started it
with um fanta tweeter of the week is how
i started it oh and then included their
name wow yeah i don't know
okay my bad i'm gonna have to uh
i'm gonna have to look it up oh jason
jason is watching here she said jason
said uh
love the gut tweets and you did it for
for rebel and one two three theory
that's right yeah exactly
yeah
yeah and i thought
that's okay that's all right it was a
great idea so um
i love that too and i have to admit it's
been harder to find people who i mean
not really i mean there's people who are
in the genre that i am in but um
not exactly you know what i mean like
we've talked about this before like
uh
a lot of people who are doing
specifically stuff around fantasy is
like you know fantasy sports
um
you know or fantasy fiction which is
sort of i mean no it's sort of in my
genre it's just not exactly so
but anyway i've been able to i've been
able to find people which is great
even think about the people you've been
retweeting
yeah
those guys you could you could recognize
yeah absolutely
because a lot of them when they get
so you know i don't always see everybody
who retweets my stuff because there's a
lot of retweets that i get on each post
so i don't
notice them so you know if you're one of
200 people retweeting somebody's message
they're probably not going to look in to
say hey who's this gen person
but if you then call them out
specifically and say hey you know you're
my fanta tweeter of the day or thank the
tweeter of the week then they're gonna
if somebody wrote that to me
i'd definitely check their profile and
see what they're all about
and because they're posting these things
they're like-minded so they're more
likely to
at least at least you pique their
curiosity at like worst case you pick
their curiosity in best case they're
checking you out and they thank you back
and maybe find some some way to work
together
yeah
absolutely i agree and even if it's just
somebody i admire i don't think it has
to be exactly you know what i mean i
think there's and there's a lot of
people who that's why i phrased it um
inspire your inspire imagination because
i think there's a lot that's that kind
of
broadens it just a little bit so
cool
so
so some of the stuff i'm looking at our
list from last month and some of the
stuff is you know we've we've done some
of it you know turning the quotes into
pictures you getting your facebook page
going and you're posting your thoughts
to twitter and facebook um but some of
the stuff we're still kind of lagging
with the blog posts and the videos and
um
so
time management always a huge
entrepreneurs right like we have these
big goals that we want to get done and
and we don't follow through on all of
them is this something that
specifically the blog posts in the
videos we've talked about this for a
couple months and and it hasn't really
been happening
is it
something that it's just a wall for you
that that uh you're resistant for some
reason or is it
can we break through this or do you want
to eliminate it
what are you feeling right now about
those two i'm feeling like i've already
broken through it um and the reason
being is i i feel like i was maybe a
little resistant only because i was
being a little bit of a perfectionist um
and
um and so i feel a lot better about it
now i do i i feel like i'm things are a
lot easier for me i've i've built in
some structure into my google calendar
and so yeah i'm i'm i'm feeling
confident i'm feeling confident i think
it was just a
a thing
maybe a wall i guess it's a way to put
it but maybe just a little resistance i
had to push through so
okay cool yeah jason brings up the point
uh what gets scheduled gets done
right can you put
a time in your schedule to do this
yes yes i did i put it on a google
calendar to do on specific days
okay and email reminders for myself so
that i you know i won't
i won't forget
but it's not about forgetting i think
it's just having that constant um
reminder just to do it even if it's not
perfect
and you know what it's not going to be
perfect
right
exactly
my first video sucked
i hated them it took me so long to do
and and i look at them when i
you know i just felt so bad about them
but uh i still put it up and you get
better you get better with each one
right and
i think for me
that
the first ones
weren't
like i knew they weren't going to be
great but i knew that each time that i
released one i would get better and
better and better and made it okay that
the first ones weren't great
and sometimes you put pressure on
yourself to make it perfect then you end
up doing nothing you get frustrated
right
exactly well your first videos are good
you started from a great position
convert to where i was and where most
people are
right right so you've got your your 10
minute homework after this call but when
is your usual structured video time
so on sundays is when i'm gonna do
um either blog post or video or both
okay so yeah
what is a reasonable
schedule
for blog posting and video
i still think of reasonable schedules
every other week i like that idea
so either a blog post or a video every
other week
and sometimes i do take some time to
write
a blog post
so i mean sometimes i'm taking a couple
weeks to actually write it
so if
it's on my calendar at least i get to
finish it so
having that scheduling that's a great
idea
yeah and if you are struggling
if you're struggling to write something
from the video again it doesn't it
doesn't have to be
the usual format that you always do it
in
it doesn't have to be perfect it can be
a quick like it's okay to do a video
that's 45 seconds long that's you on
your phone just saying something i mean
it still has to mean something to you it
does have an important message but you
don't have to have it as drawn out and
as
planned out as your new usual ones would
be and when you have the time and the
energy and focus to do it then you do
those normal ones but if something comes
up on a sunday and you can't do it
then you could still take
five minutes
and say something
right and some of the blog posts like if
you don't so here's exactly with my
newsletter i usually write my newsletter
on mondays and sometimes i'm stuck for
an idea i don't know what to do or i run
out of time because i'm busy with
something that happened to me this
this monday and i didn't i didn't know
what i was gonna do
and i ran out of
time man
you know and then there was no yeah
i know
and and i don't know if i don't always
have something great that i want to
share um
so
what i did was they usually sent out
wednesday morning on wednesday i just
pulled out
um a
video of steve jobs that i really liked
and the transcript of it and i shared
that and i just said hey here's
here's like the day steve jobs changed
my life and here's this transcript of
this video and here's the link to it to
to watch more it's something i already
had it's something that inspired me i
don't know if i had ever shared it
um
but that's what i put out and it was
still on key with my message and i spent
you know very little time put it
together
yeah my audience still loved it so yeah
totally i loved it too actually that's
funny because
i saw i had you originally you did share
it at some time and it was on you shared
the video at some point in time and i
watched it and um and then when i got
the newsletter this week i i went
through and read the whole thing again i
was kind of laughing at myself actually
because i was like i've already seen
this but i was like still compelled to
read through it
and it was like oh this is great because
it was just you know it was like fresh
again i don't know it was and it was
different to actually see it written too
than than on the video
i don't know i i enjoyed it so that's
funny okay
that's what happens when evan doesn't
have time to write his newsletter right
it was great
there's some times when it was my
birthday and i didn't have time to write
and i wrote hey guys it's my birthday
you know don't have time to write but uh
i'll see you guys in two weeks and that
that was actually one of the greatest
responses of all my newsletters just go
running back to happy birthday right
right
and just being honest with people and
letting them know you know you don't
have uh you don't have the time or you
have a busy life or whatever like
sharing that stuff helps people
get attracted to you more so you can
write a blog post and share something
really short and quick or you can do a
quick video
uh jason's writing in selfie selfie
video is sleeping the nation hot trend
right
i love it hot trend that's awesome
but um
consistency because it it trains your
audience it helps build your following
and gets people connected to you but it
also trains you
to be better at your craft doing those
short videos well
will make you better
all right right
like i'll comment on people will react
to them i'm looking forward i want my
next gen video okay
no i think that's i think gary make a
really good point because you're right
even if
even if they are even if they're
terrible and even if i didn't like even
get practice from them which obviously i
will
at least it's building that
um that muscle in in my my you know head
to keep you know consistent um which is
kind of how i started out with twitter i
mean i feel like i kind of was like okay
i'm gonna do this even though i feel
like i you know don't have anything
important to say and i kept doing it so
um
anyway yeah
i know it's hard when there's nobody
else to hold you accountable besides you
know me once a month saying jen come on
what's happening
every now and then on an email saying i
haven't seen a video for a while um
but as it grows you'll have people like
if i don't send out a newsletter people
write to me and they're like did i miss
the newsletter and so i feel
responsible for
this audience who rely and this will
happen to you like people will people
who are in a hole who are
down on themselves and are having a hard
time keeping going will rely on your
message
to help
pull them through
and if you're delivering that message
like they're going to sink deeper into
their hole
i'm curious people will
people will get there right they will
need and come to trust and wait for you
to deliver content to help them through
their problems
right
and so
if you want that to happen start acting
that way
now
okay
right like yeah right absolutely
this person
their life is gonna suck so i need to
save them with my video
absolutely i want to help encourage
people to fantasize and i agree so yeah
you're right 100
cool
okay so you've got your 10 minute
homework
and
your homework for the rest of
the month
all right so uh any questions come up
you know the drill email me during the
week
and i'm excited i'm looking forward to
this video okay
all right sounds good thank you evan
buy the laptop
okay i'm gonna do it talk to you soon
bye